[Music]
hello my friends thank you for joining
us to our program i'd like to know
we are privileged to be here with you
answering your questions
and i'd like to welcome our dear
president and speaker of secrets and
sealed pastor board as always it is a
pleasure to have you in this program
pastor
thank you danielle the feeling is mutual
thank you
and thank you also for being with us
remember that you can send your
questions to the following email tv at
some tv
dot org that is tv at some tv dot o r g
email us your questions and we will try
to answer them if there is an answer
found in the bible
before we begin i would like to
ask pastor bird to give us an opening
prayer
let's pray
father in heaven we should never open
your word we realize
without requesting your help
so we come before you today to ask that
you will be with us
to enlighten our minds
to give us
an easy way of expressing ourselves
and that those who are watching might
understand the answers to these
questions amen
there's so many questions that come up
in this world yes and we just ask lord
that you will provide those answers for
us through the ministry of your spirit
and we thank you for the promise of your
presence and we claim that promise in
the precious name of jesus
amen amen
okay let's jump to our first question
that comes from
chisanga kabwe
and the question is what is the church's
position in regards to ministers
especially pastors
eating animal flesh
and there is a second question
has it neglected the council from the
prophetess
pastor what do we say about that
well ellen white has written that
the issue of eating flesh is not a test
of fellowship that's her expression test
of fellowship
which means that if there are church
members who eat
clean meats we might say although you
wonder today whether there's anything
such as clean meats because of the
disease of the animal world
but she says that it should not be a
test of fellowship
however
she does emphasize that we should be
teaching our church members
to get off of flesh foods
because that's not the best diet
maybe i can just read a quotation i know
that you have one as well
about
specifically ministers of the gospel
correct um they're supposed to be
examples to the flock in the book
pastoral ministry page 71 that's one of
the more recent compilations of the
writings of ellen white
ellen white wrote as god's messengers
shall we not bear a decided testimony
against the indulgence of
perverted appetite
will those who claim to be ministers of
the gospel notice who claimed to be
ministers of the gospel
proclaiming the most solemn truth ever
given to mortals
make the stomach a
cesspool that's quite a strong
expression
god has provided an abundance of fruits
and grains
which may be helpfully prepared and used
in proper quantities
why then do men continue to choose flesh
meats
can we possibly have confidence in
ministers
who at tables where flesh is served
join with others
in eating it that's a very strong
statement it is
pastors really need to be examples to
the flock
uh when it comes to the issue of health
reform
yes
i like to add
this other quotation that we find in
councils on diet and food page 399
it goes in the same lines
let not any of our ministers
set an evil example in the eating of
flesh meat
let them and their families live up to
the light of health reform
let not our ministers animalize their
own nature and the nature of their
children
interesting
so that that also affects the family
well the issue i understand this
this is not easy for some people
i mean there are some pastors that
grew up
in places where this is the staple food
right even some that grew up in a home
that was poor and all they had was this
in some places is more affordable to eat
meat than buy
vegetables or fruits
and yet
we should not rest the power of god
the bible says that we can do all things
through jesus christ who strengthens us
especially today
we
let's say not
let us not mention
religious reasons for that but even
atheists
physicians doctors today
many people agree that a plant-based
diet
is a better option yeah people are into
vegan
and organic even though organic is much
more expensive you know people are
really uh waking up to the fact that
they need to take care of their health
you know there's there's something else
which is really important and that is
that ellen white herself
struggled
to overcome flesh that's a good point
yes and uh repeatedly you know she had
to struggle with it and it lasted years
uh so
uh you know
the problem is when you try to justify
it
yes
it's another thing when you say man i
was brought up this way you know it's so
difficult like ellen white eventually
said to her stomach stomach
you will eat healthful food or you will
not eat at all
and you know she had lapses after that
but eventually she overcame the use of
flesh foods and so it's not to say that
ministers who have been eating meat all
their lives
it will be an easy thing
but but that's what ministers need to
work towards because ellen white is very
clear on that particular point amen and
before we move to the next question
another
point that i want to make i believe is
very important
also be loving and kind in the way you
treat with pastors who have not overcome
at this point
because we can sometimes be
very unchrist-like in the way we handle
these matters and that actually hardens
the pastor's heart and
he's he has authority
and he can easily
make himself felt
in this issue so be kind be courteous
try to win your pastor with a
christ-like attitude
and that would be a great testimony for
him now you know the apostle paul kind
of addressed this issue
uh when he dealt with the
with the matter of
eating meat that was offered to idols
you know he criticized those who were
criticizing those who ate meat that was
offered to idols
because you know it's one thing to eat
flesh and then it's another thing to eat
other people yeah yes so that's even
worse so we should you know we should be
kind we should be nice
but we should also teach health reform
amen in the church uh another thing
which is important pastor and that is
that
if we're going to go
part way we need to go the whole way
you know there are those who don't eat
meat but they overdose on sugar
and they overdose on fatty foods and
they criticize people who eat meat well
the ideal is that we return to god's
original plan in every sphere of life
amen including overeating sugar
fat
you know getting enough
exercise uh getting enough sleep uh
getting fresh air sunshine all of the
the
you know the way that god has given us
to conserve our health that's a good
point remember that we
god gave us eight laws of health as we
know them not just one eating is just
one but there is more exercise rest but
as pastor
bohr has mentioned it
very well pastor i think we can move on
to our next question let's move on to
the next one i have it here you know
this is one that we've already answered
before
so
i'm just going to ask you one question
regarding the specific
point of controversy
with regards to this this is the
question
this has been a hard subject for me to
grasp my mind around
it seems very deep and complicated
please provide a short version
juiced version
of what lgt
simply is that is last generation
theology
and if we are to have the
last generation theology characteristics
for the day of the lord to come
and of course my question would be this
pastor and that is
what is sin i think it all boils down to
what sin is you don't we don't have
dedicated a long time to these questions
because we did an entire symposium but i
think it'd be important to define what
sin is
well the bible is clear and ellen
elliott confirms this that there is only
one definition of sin
and we find it in
first john 3 4 sin is the transgression
of the law so our definition of sin is
sin by choice i choose to transgress
god's law
sin we are not sinners by nature we are
sinners by choice
so
as you said pastor boer
this controversy about that last
generation theology and
here we also have the nature of christ
which is part of it
this all can be easily clarified when we
have a biblical answer to the question
of sin
so is it possible to overcome sin before
the close of probation that's the big
question that's a big question amen
i believe so the bible tells it
we can do all things through jesus
christ who strengthens us jude 24 says
that he is able to keep us from falling
we have we have a generation a group of
people
uh in revelation 14 12 here are the is
the patience of the saints here are they
that keep the commandments of god and
the faith of jesus so it says the
commandments all of them so there will
be a generation there will be a people
that will keep all the commandments of
god even though they they have a falling
human nature so the bottom line is that
we every day we need to get closer and
closer to jesus because if we abide in
him
we will overcome amen
you know we don't overcome in our own
strength because we don't have any any
strength to overcome
but when we get close to him and we
abide in him
it is possible to overcome sin that's
right i mean yeah
okay so what's our next question
um before we move to our next question
uh is to remember to remind our viewers
that
secrets and seal produce a
really good program a symposium on last
generation theology
and you can find it or on our youtube
channel
symposium last generation symposium
and you will find answers to all your
questions there yeah and i might mention
something else pastor and that is that
pastor daniel
one of his responsibilities here at
secrets unsealed is to coordinate the
hispanic programming
and he's done some phenomenal
preparation work for a symposium on last
generation theology in spanish
and you'll have more information on on
that very very soon amen we have we're
going to be doing a week-long series
and probably somewhere between 24 and 30
uh presentations along with town halls
so
stay tuned
for that information and i hope that
you're able to tune in amen thank you
pastor
okay our next question comes
from
hello samtv
kindly explained to me the
12 90 and 13 35 days found in daniel 12.
thank you
well the bottom line is that
we have 28 minutes for this program
and
to answer this question we would need
them to be prophetic minutes
yes
because it's very involved they're very
complex
these time periods are found in daniel
chapter 12.
and all i can do is suggest materials
where this person can actually do
his own research
first of all we have a series here that
is called the 1260 1290 and 1335 days
very good there's actually three i think
three cds they're also on an mp3 where
there's a full analysis of these time
periods
there's also a book that was published
by the michigan conference it's called
prophetic principles where you have
several chapters
that deal with the 1260 1290 and 1335.
also we carry books by heidi hikes
where he deals with the specific date of
508 538 1798 and 1843
which is the the ending of the 1335 days
a great original resource material by
heidi hikes
so i would recommend that
that this individual
go
get the the mp3 with our presentation
also get the book prophetic principles
as well as the material by heidi hikes
no need to reinvent the wheel but in
short
just to give a short answer to the
question the 1260 we know are from 538
to 1798 it's a period of papal dominion
the 1290 begin in 508 and go to 1798.
it's from the first time that the papacy
received temporal power through clovis
king of the franks
and then the 1335 take us from 508 to
1843 1844
so that's a historicist view which
is pretty close to being
the church view
correct and they have a place in history
but cannot be reapplied right because uh
maybe the question although the person
doesn't mention it
but today many are reapplying the
prophetic periods of daniel 12. right
but historically if we use the
historical flow method the year-day
principle the year-day principle
we find these prophetic periods in a
specific time in history they had a
historical fulfillment
the principles
will be repeated in the sense of the
conflict
but not the time itself right
good point
all right what's the next question that
we have
well we have here
several questions in one this one comes
from anna lugube
greetings pastors thank you for the good
work you're doing may the lord bless you
and your families
questions when did saul
become paul so that's the first one okay
that's a very good question
and i think the answer might be in acts
acts 39
yup
so what can we say about that
well i was looking at the name
and saul
which is reference to king saul it was a
hellenized jewish form
of the name but then paul paulus
it was a latin name
which means small
i heard once someone but i don't have a
reference to prove this that
the reason why paul decided to be called
or saul decided to be called paul is
because
he
he felt himself so small even in
comparison to the first king of of
israel saul and he didn't want to be
looked up as
as a having the same name of the first
king of israel but in his eyes he was
very small so he decided to be called
paul paulus
it's interesting that in
acts chapter 13
verses one and two it says now in the
church that was at antioch there was a
certain
prophets and teachers
barnabas simeon who was called niger
lucius of cyrene manian who had been
brought up with herod
the tetrarch and saul
as they ministered to the lord and
fasted the holy spirit said now separate
to me barnabas and saul
for the work to which i have called them
so at that point he's being called saul
but then when you go down to verse 13
it says now when paul and his party set
sell for payphofs
they came to perga and so on
so suddenly
saul is paul and uh perhaps the reason
why saul was changed to paul is because
paul
is a a word that
is from the latin
right which would uh be closer to the
ministry of paul to the gentiles
so so basically
i think it's the it's at the point of
the laying on of hands on barnabas and
paul
that now uh he's called paul rather than
saul
very good
okay
so the next question is
during jesus's time there was a lot of
demon activities
some people's illness were due to demon
possession and jesus cast out the demons
based on that
there is a question can our pastors cast
out demons
yes pastors
by the power of the holy spirit
can cast out demons amen not the pastor
you know the pastor by himself without
the holy spirit is in grave danger like
we know uh from that experience of those
who are casting out demons in the name
of jesus
[Laughter]
so so we need to make sure that we have
to be very close to the lord jesus
before we start uh uh practicing
exorcisms
amen yes mark 16 17 jesus promised
before he
ascended and this is in reference to the
power of the holy spirit pentecost
and these signs will these signs will
follow those who believe
notice those who believe right in my
name they will cast out demons
they will speak with new tongues and
they will take up serpents and they
if they drink anything deadly it will by
no means hurt them
so some people drink poison they presump
presumptuously say the lord is going to
protect me and there are religions
christian religions that actually pick
up snakes poisonous snakes
because god promised that he's going to
protect people from poisonous snakes
well he protects them from poisonous
snakes like he did when paul the snake
came out and bit someone
uh you know then god can intervene but
the sin of presumption is saying ah god
is gonna protect me uh you know that's
uh that's the same sin that satan wanted
jesus
to perform when he uh when he said jump
from the temple tower that's right
so
the condition here is
those who believe
and those who believe receive the power
of the holy spirit to do this amen and
the only reason is to further the gospel
it's not just to show that i have power
but there will be moments that we need
that and god will give us the power if
we believe amen amen well there's a
there's a second sub-point under this
question of you know jesus casting out
demons
um and that is do
you think
that today some diseases are due to
demon possession
what do you think well i believe so
actually i
i am reading the early letters of lng
white that
up to
2015 some of them were unpublished
and she recounts her experiences
traveling in new york and new england
and how most like many of them got sick
many times and then she says
satan had brought disease upon them
because he was trying to hinder their
work
so some diseases yes are due to
i would not say demon
possession in this case but satan
definitely is the author
of disease now other times
disease is the result of the violation
of the loss of health so there are many
reasons for this is we cannot say that
all disease is demon possession
but certainly in some instances
satan is the one that works yes
in bringing disease like in the case of
job yeah god gave him permission and job
went and he afflicted job with this
terrible disease
satan also tried to kill ill and white
he did yes in jackson michigan you know
when they were after she had the great
controversy vision
uh you know on the way back on the train
she and her husband were talking about
the publishing of the book
what became the book of great
controversy originally it was spiritual
gifts
and satan was there listening to their
conversation he says i can't let this
book come out
and so in jackson michigan ellen white
had a stroke
and she could only write one page and
then she had to rest three days to write
another page
and rest three days
and as she did that she said i got
stronger and stronger and the final
result is the book the great controversy
amen so you know satan can definitely
afflict people with disease
not every case like you said because
some people because of bad health habits
or perhaps inheritance from their
ancestors you know can also
be diseased like for example diabetes
type 1 yes
and so on
so the answer to that do do you think
that today some diseases are due to
demon possession
i would say to demon harassment
more than more than demon possession
and then the third question is can good
angels possess human beings like satan's
angels
well it
i would rephrase the question
because possess has that connotation of
taking control of your will
and your concern without your consent
and
god's angels are not going to do that
right
but we do have instances where
god supernaturally intervened
in a specific situation for example
balaam
he went with a wrong purpose to curse
israel
but the holy spirit intervened yeah
and he ended up blessing israel right we
also find the example of saul and his
messengers he was pursuing david he
wanted to kill david and
now david is with samuel at the school
of the prophet and eventually all of
them end up prophesying and the spirit
of the lord rested upon him
so
but
even in these cases we do not see god's
will or god trying to
take control of your will without your
consent right right so in that sense
they do not possess
other people yeah ellen white does have
statements where she says that that the
angels will bring
words to our memory
she says that they will enlighten people
who are searching for the truth
you know but but as far as
possessing
an individual against their will
the angels don't operate that way god
doesn't operate that way you know god
operates uh in a way where we must
consent
and make a choice of our own will and
then when we give him permission
then the angels can come and do their
work
amen
okay uh one final question i think this
doesn't need a lot of time to answer it
and it's a question in regards to church
services worship services that if it is
okay if the elders decons and
deaconesses choir members to sit
on the pulpit during worship service
well i hope they don't sit on the pulpit
i think a person means on the stage
because you wouldn't sit on the pulpit
sure yes
but we we know what the person means
i don't see any problem
with
you know elders as it says here deacons
and deaconesses sitting choir members
sitting on the stage fresno central
church the orchestra is on the stage
and all of the participants come up to
the stage for the pastoral prayer for
the sermon and for the special music and
so on i don't find anything in the
bible or spirit of prophecy that would
forbid
individuals that have church office to
occupy a place on the stage
however
i remember when i was a child
you know
children were not allowed to go onto the
platform and run around and play around
no no because it was a sacred place
and i think that uh we need to be very
careful about uh
something happening such as that yeah so
the principle then is reverence for the
house of god for the place of worship
but
the sitting on the stage
sitting there doesn't necessarily mean
that there is irreverence right depends
on what they're doing while the sermon
is being presented yeah i think that we
need to be very careful not to
go beyond
what the bible and the spirit of
prophecy tell us amen about reverence in
the house of god amen well folks
time flies by so fast
and we're nearing the end of our program
we want to thank you for tuning in today
and for every time that we have this
special program i'd like to know
remember it's a question and answer
program where you can send us your
questions we'll do the research and if
there's a biblical answer we will
provide it
the address is tv
at some tv tv.org once again tv at
suntv.org once again thank you for
joining us
god bless you
and we hope to see you the next time
[Music]
you